if i could switch wine cellars with any
player in a one-on-one game
i would switch with ooh take a little
sip on that one
i gotta take a sip on that one who do
you think's got a better better wine
cellar jj jimmy butler
jimmy butler has the most diversity in
his cellar i'm not gonna beat him
one-on-one but if i could
we are here on full body today with the
pride and joy of the lehigh
mountain hawks the man the myth the
legend of the portland trailblazers
the skills and drills master cj mccullum
thank you again for coming
and having a glass or glasses with us so
all three of these wines
meant something not only to me in my
story to you
but i felt like in relation to your
story your life story
let's start with your why first
you know how the game is a business at
the same time how have you dealt with
not only trade rumors but maybe
sometimes not always getting the credit
you have
deserved for evolving your game to start
with development it's just been the
story of my life just work hard work for
what you want
and kind of continue to have to prove
yourself over and over again as i
continued to work and finally got a
chance i just didn't want to blow it and
i think throughout the course of my
career
i've had to kind of reinvent myself and
kind of prove myself each year improving
my consistency
prove i can score first at this level
then prove i can be a facilitator at
this level and i think
eight years later five years as a
starter dame and i have been able to
make the playoffs
seven straight years we've been able to
coexist we've been able to thrive
together empower each other
and my game has evolved to the point to
where this year you know obviously
before i got hurt i was shooting
10 11 threes a game hitting you know
four five threes at night i was
averaging five assists
i was helping lead our team in a lot of
different statistical categories but
also from a leadership standpoint
yeah you were balling now you was
different let me give you credit because
you've taken your role of leadership i'm
like dang like
this this dude is taking it to the next
level so i think to correlate that to
your wine i think
to have the opportunity to be in this
business
and to not only put your signature on
your wine but to make sure that you're
trying to get better at it every single
day is
ridiculously tight and i'm pretty pretty
excited to be in this
business with you if you had to play
somebody one-on-one for their wine
cellar
who would it be oh
[Music]
you got to take a little sip on that one
i gotta take a sip on that one
if i could switch wine cellars with any
player in a one-on-one game i would
switch with
who do you think's got a better better
wine cellar jj jimmy butler
jimmy butler has the most diversity in
his cellar i'm not gonna beat him
one-on-one but if i could
right i would get his cellar i like
somebody where you could say what part
of the world you want to go to
do you have a riesling in your cellar do
you have a chilean wine in your cellar
do you have some new worlds
you know sonoma coast do you have some
you know walla walla
merlot or some red mountain cabernet
from washington so
that is what i like like one is so vast
that's why i mentioned jimmy because i
know he's
well versed in in traveling throughout
europe and being in france
being in some other different areas so
he would bring me he would expose me to
some things i haven't tasted like mello
mello loves white burgundy jj loves
white burgundy they got a nice mixture
of
things that i wouldn't normally have in
my rotation describe these players
uh with a specific either bottle or
varietal of wine
wow so we're going gonna start with
lebron wow
man he's like uh i mean you want what
you want american you want
burgundy no no worldly worldly we could
go all over the world i'm with you
you know you got brown who's arguably
the best player to ever play the game so
like depending on what your favorite
wine is
that exists i mean he's like he's a
chateau margot man
in terms of like what i would drink he
was great early
you know he was he was deemed the chosen
one yeah
and he's been able to kind of extend his
career 18 years later to where he's
sharper
he's a better jump shooter than he was
when he first got into the league still
able to empower his teammates still able
to make his team win and still
depending on who you argue with is still
the best player in the nba so i think
you know from a price point standpoint
you look the top shot you see how
you see how he's moving the needle yeah
oh yeah trading cards
everything in that realm and then his
impact off the court i think you look at
wines and what they've been able to do
for people you talk about bringing
families together
being able to give people wines share
wines with certain people
i think he's done the same thing with
his with his uh platform which
he shared to the communities he shared
to the kids that come from where we come
from so i would say
he's top shelf he's he's the type of
wine that you know your wife won't touch
while you're out of town
all right so how about i'm gonna go
young fella lamella ball
lamello ball he's probably i mean
definitely new world
okay okay he's so young you know what i
mean he's got potential to be like opus
you know what i mean yeah i said it he's
got the potential to be open the ceiling
is
the ceiling is very very high a lot of
upside
you know i would definitely say the
acidity levels are high you know
the game you know the game is like
it leaves you like wow like he's he's
ahead of his time from a vision
standpoint
um like when mike is saying that he's
better than we thought you know
you're doing what you're supposed to do
let's go to the next one right and i
think the next one
would be my one you are really good at a
lot of things
outside of basketball whether you're the
vice president mbpa whether you're doing
stuff when it comes to bitcoin nfts
whether you're doing the mental health
whether you're doing a show
so how do you do that like how do you
find time for all these things and
what is your motivation to being like
that answer that question to like kids
who are 14 and 15 where people tell them
just stick to basketball basketball has
always been an escape
and i've always wanted to use the game i
think a lot of times we allow the game
to use us
right you know we put our heart and soul
into it we don't really have plans on
what we're like outside of basketball we
have no identity outside of basketball
and then when it stops we struggle we
struggle financially or we struggle
mentally
we struggle physically from an exercise
standpoint because we've depended on
sport for so long we have nothing
being a guy who didn't have a lot of
scholarships was able to go to a school
like lehigh
get a degree pursue a career in
journalism i just wanted to make sure
that i had
everything in place outside of
basketball as well
right totally basketball has always been
my plan a but i was
my plan a involved using basketball to
get plan b podcast
plan c sharpen up my my college degree
uh from a journalism standpoint
part d you know make sure i'm exposing
myself to different um
different avenues so that i have
different streams of income and i think
for
the the 14 or 15 year old that's
listening to this people are going to
tell you a lot of things aren't possible
they're going to tell you a lot of
things can't happen to you
because it didn't happen for them let's
go to that last one
it's alexander you know journeys have to
begin somewhere
and this summer i actually had a chance
to come here because some people can
make wine but there's
other people that put passion inside
their wine which makes it taste better
so i i liken this to you as like they
just don't do
wine from the willamette valley they do
a little wine from argentina they do
some stuff from napa
they make a riesling which is next level
here but you
you do different things at a top level
and one thing that's new
that i try to explain to people is the
nba top shop and so from your
perspective where is that going
how is that evolving people are starting
to learn more about it the highlight
factor
and i would have liken it to it's
similar to the trading card industry in
which
right right the quantity kind of
determines the quality a lot of times
now totally the lebron
duh is this the lebron dunk on jason
terry and they and do they only make
five of them or do they make 20 of them
yeah like that was a that was an iconic
play it was like a once in a lifetime
situation to which
if top shot puts that out i bet you they
probably only put 23 out for one because
he's number 23 and for two because it's
an iconic moment
and that kind of drives the market value
but i think
top shot is the future i think nft is
the future in being able to
have a collection that you can store
online that can be safe encrypted
is much easier than me trying to like
remember trading cards that i had when i
was 15 years old so i think this
i think this new space of being able to
store things online in general
is the wave i think nft is the future
when you find the right products
to buy and i think top shot is smart for
capitalizing on sports
it sucks that i have to pay for my own
moments you know what i mean like i'm
trying to buy like my moment like my
pull-up which is crazy
so we wanted to do a small little game
right and those have been already poured
i ain't gonna lie to you i'm not very
good at these games but that's all right
this time i will tell you i did a blind
tasting with melo
and he had the year down and we actually
went to alexander
and he was getting the ears though was
he one of these isn't from oregon or two
of them are from oregon
well he got figured out this one is not
from oregon for sure
i know what i just had is definitely a
pinot noir
this is not from here i don't know where
it's from but it wasn't from here
you know what's crazy i can almost tell
you oh no that's definitely not a peanut
butter
oh this is the oregon pinot
wow that has a lot of tannins
but i still don't think it's a world
wine did you do the swish
oh yeah you have to do the swish you got
to feel that grip on the teeth
i'm just going to say that is the oregon
pinot right there right
like oregon peanut butter is another
country yeah yeah yeah this one's
definitely from another country
we all agreed that the second one is a
pinot
one of them is not from america and the
other one has to be
i think one of them might be a cab you
know what
let me check yes let me check the
bottles
yeah what do we got we got a ravina
which is
napa and then we got alexander pino
oh i should have known that i appreciate
your time this has been great
thank you for being on full body thank
you for having me on man
i just want to say as a as a black man
who's
entering the wine space continue to
break barriers and continue to enjoy
all the hard work you put in on and off
the court and continue to be that
celebrity
that you are cheers to that big duck
you